cette vidéo est sponsorisé par kambly
une plateforme pour améliorer votre
anglais vous en parle enfin de vidéos
you les paras potes
j'espère que vous allez bien trop
content de refaire ce format le premier
vous a beaucoup plu je vous rappelle
rapidement le concept il y à un sobre et
dit qu'ils s'appellent à main et vit à
sol en fait il ya des gens qui viennent
dessus et qui raconte des trucs qu'ils
ont fait ils savent pas si si c'est des
bâtards ou si c'est des gens bien et
donc nous on va lire leur histoire et on
va un peu les juges et en plus j'aime
beaucoup ce en mars que ça me permet
d'être voilà c'est un une autre ambiance
me lâcher un peu plus être un peu plus
énergique je peux faire des mouvements
comme ceci voilà alors est-ce que je
suis un bâtard attendez on parle c'est
un homme une femme
on ne sait pas je crois enfin comme si
c'était un homme parfois et parfois que
yo c'est le sérieux du montage en fait
je me rends compte que j'ai même pas lu
le titre du post c'est en gros suis-je
un bâtard ou une merde pour ne pas avoir
rendu une grande somme d'argent que j'ai
lus en donnant un organe parce que le
receveur est mort avant que je puisse le
2 mai ma mère biologique et tadic à la
drogue n'ai jamais rencontré et mon père
biologique m'a donné à sa soeur et son
mari pour kim élèves commencent avec une
bonne situation initiale je considère
mon oncle et ma tante comme mes parents
et j'ai des sentiments négatifs à propos
de mon père ça peut se comprendre les
sentiments négatifs
il y a deux ans voilà je les lui en
anglais j'ai un frisson il ya deux ans
son fils le plus jeune avait besoin d'un
don d'organe pour vivre j'ai été
d'accord pourra tester pour voir si je
pouvais être le donneur seulement si mon
père me donner une certaine somme
d'argent
si j'étais un donneur potentiel ça a
sûrement l'air d'être une phrase de
bâtard mais en vrai je connais pas du
tout mais demi frères et soeurs et j'ai
pas d'amour pour eux ni pour mon père
mon père n'avait pas trop les mecs sains
pour tous ceux qui ont l'impression que
leur famille c'est complexe
ce genre de poste peut être rassurant
j'ai été testés et on a vu que j'étais
un donneur potentiel j'ai reçu l'argent
gelé utiliser immédiatement pour
rembourser mon prêt étudiant et j'ai
utilisé le reste pour acheter 40 % d'une
maison mais avant que la chirurgie et
lieu le fils de mon père est mort à on
le sent venir comme une maison à on le
sent venir là j'ai envoyé mes
condoléances mais je n'ai pas offert le
fait de rendre l'argent puisque j'avais
déjà dépensé mon père savait que cet
argent était déjà dépensé aussi et bien
cette année
mon père et sa femme ont commencé à me
demander à ce que je les rembourse
je refuse parce que j'ai pas contrôler
le fait que leur fils meurt j'avais déjà
planifié tout pour pouvoir faire le don
d'organes
j'ai fait ma part du deal en montrant
mon intention est ce que je suis un
bâtard ça nous aidera de savoir c'est
combien mais bon ce que ça joue géants
sont que la somme quand même joue un peu
là dedans franchement ça va être un bon
paquet d'argent quand même s'il a réussi
à rembourser son prêt étudiant écarts
importants d'une maison c'est compliqué
parce qu'en même temps je comprends la
position du dard ont aussi quoi et
quelqu'un dans les commentaires qui dit
est ce que ton père biologique a promis
de te payer si tu te faisais testé pour
être un match potentiel ou est ce que
l'argent était censé être offert
seulement s'il y avait vraiment la
donation et vous la juste une plutôt
parce que ton père était excité au cas
où des gens se demandent c'est exact sur
la raison pour laquelle on fait pas de
gros arrangements financiers entre
membres de la même famille
ça devient le bordel et rajoute aussi je
ne suis pas avocat
mais je suis à peu près sûr que payer
quelqu'un pour donner un organe est
super illégal alors il répond à ça il
dit l'argent a été transféré après que
la chirurgie était planifiée et j'avais
toutes les intentions d'y aller j'ai
demandé à avoir l'argent avant la
chirurgie parce que mon père pourrait
très bien ne pas payer après et moi j'ai
aucun moyen légal de lui demander cet
argent après pour moi le fait que ce
soit illégale entre guillemets de payer
pour recevoir un don d'organes etc
pour moi ce cette illégalité la haye
rentre pas dans le débat de est ce que
c'est un bâtard ou part parce que c'est
deux personnes consentantes qui font
leur accord il est illégal
oui mais c'est pas ça qui va faire de
lui un bâtard dans ce contexte là ça
peut faire de lui quelqu'un de coupable
aux yeux de la loi etc
mais pour moi c'est deux choses
différentes en fait des choses que je
pourrais faire qu'ils sont illégales et
qui pourtant sont éthiques c'est chaud
quand même c'est chaud parce que
clairement cet argent c'était pour la
chirurgie donc techniquement il aurait
pas dû dépenser cet argent avant de
faire la chirurgie c'est son erreur ça
et donc pour moi il doit rentrer
d'argent il peut y avoir une petite
compensation pour le fait qu'il ait pris
un rendez-vous qui soit fait tester etc
d'accord mais le reste de l'argent je
pense mesdames et messieurs que nous
sommes face un bâtard est ce que c'est
la première merle de ce format ce
possible est-ce que je suis un bâtard
avoir demandé à ma femme de se la fermer
déjà si ça s'arrête là oui parce qu'elle
a dit que je ne savais rien de notre
fille ma femme et moi on a une fille de
6 mois
c'est notre premier enfant on apprend
voilà tout ce qui est l'éducation
parentale etc
on apprend sur le tas notre fille est
génial cependant comme beaucoup de bébés
elle a des problèmes au niveau du
sommeil elle se réveille une fois au
mieux de la nuit après autour de minuit
1h du matin et elle met une demi heure à
45 minutes sont couchés rien de fou mais
c'est une situation est stressante pour
nous on juge on juge dans cette émission
on juge des amis c'est stressant ça
franchement vous n'êtes pas prêt pour ce
qui vous attends je crois ma femme a
toujours était anxieuse elle est encore
plus à propos de notre fille elle veut
s'assurer qu'elles se développent bien
qu'elle a les bons soins etc
cependant lorsqu'il s'agit du fait de
dormir l'anxiété le stress de ma femme
est totalement en limite genre à la
minute où ma fille commence à pleurer au
milieu de la nuit
ma femme est en train de stresser en
mode oh mon dieu elle va jamais se
recoucher est-ce quelque chose qui va
pas à son devrait appeler les médecins
malheureusement vu que les choses
s'empirent à propos du sommeil elle
commence à m'insulter
genre tu sais pas ce qu'il faut faire
avec elle je suis avec elle toute la
journée
tu sais pas comment prendre soin d elle
cependant le matin s excuse toujours
près de moi avance rapide a aujourd'hui
notre fille ça fait trois jours de suite
qu'elle se réveille au milieu de la nuit
ce qui est anormal on est un petit peu
tendu aujourd'hui notre fille a eu une
mauvaise sieste à la crèche et donc elle
a eu du mal à s'endormir
ce qui n'est pas habituel quand la mise
au lit elle a commencé à pleurer tout de
suite jusque là franchement moi je n'ai
pas d'enfants mais ça a l'air d'être le
brief peut-être qu'on les a pas prévenus
ma femme a commencé à stresser en mode
renan c'est reparti être éveillé toute
la nuit et tu vas rien faire comme
d'habitude la petite balle perdue je lui
demande de se calmer et elle a répondu
en disant nous ne devons pas de me
calmer tu ne la connais pas tu ne sait
rien d'elle tu ne sais pas t'occuper ce
à quoi je vais répondu qu'elle devrait
fermer sa gueule ses deux fils du
chevalement et qu'évidemment je connais
ma fille et que je sais m'en occuper
elle m'a dit que j'avais aucun droit de
lui dire de fermer sa gueule et c'est
parti en sucette
avec du recul j'ai probablement un petit
peu sur réagit cependant c'était
extrêmement blessant que
ma femme me disent que je ne sais pas
comment gérer ma fille que je la connais
pas et c est ce que je suis un bâtard
parce que j'ai dit à ma femme de se la
fermer
quand elle m'a dit que je ne sais pas
comment m'occuper de ma fille c'est un
peu fort le dire que tu as un bâtard
pour ça mais oui c'est jamais cool de
demander à personne avec qui on est de
fermer sa gueule c'est quand même
violence est de l'ordre de l'insulté
tous et la communication violence c'est
pas cool après j'ai l'impression que
c'est des schémas qui reviennent souvent
dans les couples genre le mec il a du
mal parfois à trouver sa place
après ça dépend évidemment des couples
invités une grosse généralité mais en
tout cas les couples que moi j'ai vu que
les mecs voilà ils aient du mal à
trouver leur place et que en fait les
meuf elle s'en occupe plus et donc du
coup elles ont appris à faire les trucs
et le mec il est un peu à la ramasse qui
n'a pas forcément appris en même temps
et donc du coup il ya un déséquilibre
qui se crée qui se maintient parce que à
la fois et le mec qui du coup bas il va
pas trop savoir quoi faire et du coup il
est un peu tombé et de l'oatei à la meuf
qui elle l a compris comment faire le
truc et je gère le truc est limitée elle
n'a pas envie que le gars s'en occupe à
ce qu'elle aime à le faire donc est ce
que c'est un bâtard non c'est un bâtard
le terme est un peu fort je trouve
c'est une discussion qui dérape ça
arrive dans les comptes irene qui dit ta
femme a peut-être un post partum
hangzhou haïti où des pressions donc
j'imagine une anxiété ou une dépression
post 1 tu as si c'est le cas elle a
besoin d'aidé de soutien et pas qu'on
lui dise de fermer sa gueule oui est-ce
que je suis un bâtard pour avoir défendu
ma femme et sa belle fille aura rompu
nos règles de la maison que je trouve
stupide j'ai donc c'est un homme de 45
ans un fils de 18 ans et une fille de
vingt deux ans ma femme 44 ans et elle a
une fille de 21 ans et ensemble on a une
fille de 15 ans donc ils sont six à la
messe 3 2 et une en plus on est tous à
la maison ensemble sauf la fille de 15
ans qui va à l'école mais le reste de
nos enfants sont au college en ligne ma
fille de 22 ans galère avec son
addiction à l'alcool notamment à cause
de la culture dans les collèges
américains
et aussi parce que s est
s'automédicamenter déjà à cause de
douleurs au dos extrême à cause de sa
scoliose elle a réussi à trouver un
psychothérapeute pas trop cher et nous a
tous convaincus de faire une session
tous ensemble familiale on a appris
durant cette séance familiale que ma
fille a convaincu le psychothérapeute
que elle se sent faible à chaque fois
que l'alcool est accessible
immédiatement à elle et son frère se
sentent aussi tri-gate ça déclenche un
truc chez eux dès qu'ils entendent de la
musique forte parce que ça les ramène
dans ses soirées et qui était plein
d'alcool soirée qui était organisé par
leur propre mère à part moi j'avoue
j'aurais aimé que le poste soit créé par
la mer salaires beaucoup plus drôle mais
on va continuer ma fille nous a en gros
tenu en otage pendant la session jusqu'à
ce que le psychothérapeute suggère qu'on
ne laisse pas d'alcool à la maison
points c'est fort le moins tenu en otage
c'est très fort et aussi laisser la
musique un niveau assez faible
ma femme est assez fier de sa collection
de vins et d'autres alcools et elle
était un peu vénère
les ca des amis gromov quand même quand
tu as une collection et que tu le
laisses à des amis comme ça c'est pas
rien ça pas rien ma belle fille et ma
fille de 15 ans ont commencé à poster en
ligne sur le fait que la se plaignaient
de leur soeur de 22 ans qui a transformé
leur maison en état policier quelque
part et leurs amis ont appelé donc ma
fille de 22 ans alcoolique en ligne pas
très cool
pas très cool la semaine dernière quand
j'étais pas là j'ai appris que ma fille
de 15 ans a appris qu'elle était entrée
dans l'équipe officielle de l'école de
golf
total respect pour le golf mais j'avoue
je jugeais je me suis imaginé l'équipe
universitaire de golf
ça m'a fait rire et donc elle sa soeur
et ma femme elles ont décidé d'inviter
des amis et leur mère et tous pour
célébrer ma femme a vu sa fille donc sa
propre fille de 21 ans boire des
boissons alcoolisées et a décidé que
c'était voilà c'était quand même le jour
de ce détente novembre où il ya de
vingt-et-une personnes qui ont commencé
à boire et ensuite mes deux enfants sont
arrivées à la maison donc les deux qui
avait des problèmes avec les soirs et il
ya eu un clash ou ma femme du coup leur
a dit qu' il n'avait pas à rester si
vous voulez que ce n'était pas leur
soirée et que c'était pour l'heure deux
miss france rentre à la maison on m'a
raconté la même histoire des deux côtés
et finalement j'ai demandé à ma fille
combien de temps elle attendait de nous
que l'on vive sous la prohibition dans
cette maison et que les règles de cette
maison était stupide et que c'était une
bonne chose pour ma femme de réaliser
que c'était aussi sa maison et celle de
ses enfants
aya du clash et j'ai dit à ma fille que
elle pouvait travailler et trouver son
propre endroit c'est le souhaitait
est-ce que je suis un bâtard à [ __ ]
est-ce que je suis un bâtard d'être sous
l'effet que tout le monde se plie à
l'alcoolique de la famille ou en hyper
violent la phrase non ma femme sa fille
ses amis ce sont des gens qui boivent de
manière sociale et qui peuvent arrêter
après un 0 2 c'est ma fille qui est
dysfonctionnel bon bon bon endroit mais
il aurait pu être résolu simplement on
aurait pu dire à la fille écoute cette
soirée là bas y boire de l'alcool
ces mules soit pas là
mais voilà c'est juste une soirée je
comprends que ce soit des règles
compliquées qu'est ce que j'en pense moi
c'est du rhin celui-là il est pas
évidence trop bon je trouve que déjà sa
manière de parler à sa fille est pas ouf
mais après ça soit je le dis juste à
nous il lui a pas parlé comme ça après
il est il est saoul et il est sous les
situations peut-être que ça vaut le coup
d'aller voir aussi un autre
psychothérapeute on va voir un autre son
de cloche
parce que ce serait que dire comme
solution est bas juste pas d'alcool à la
maison du tout le psychothérapeute il a
été un peu peut-être qu'ils avaient
d'autres pistes à explorer il ya
forcément des environnements où la
fillette va se retrouver et y'aura
l'alcool aussi en fuite sur la fille de
22 ans qui a commencé à
s'automédicamenter on sait d'où leur de
scoliose c'est vrai que ce passage à un
peu chelou tepa censée laisser son
enfant s'automédicamenter quoi donc
l'encadrement familial parce qu'en plus
on a un portrait de la mère si organiser
cette grosse grosse teuf
on sent que l'encadrement familial est
pas hyper protecteur j'ai l'impression
ça qui est aussi ce qui se passe en
ligne et donc on lui demande est ce que
il a fait quelque chose pour arrêter ça
que le fait qu'elles se fassent appeler
alcoolique et ou en ligne mais dans tous
les cas on en revient à la question
initiale qui est de défendre sa femme et
sa belle fille et de dire que les règles
sont stupides pour moi c'est deux choses
différentes dire que les règles sont
stupides
ah c'est pas ce qu'on attend de toi en
tant que père j'imagine plat tu fais
comme si tu subis ces règles aussi et
donc tu te plains du symptôme
il faudrait peut-être s'attaque à la
maladie donc est ce que c'est un bâtard
un petit peu est ce que je dis ça parce
qu'on manque de bâtard dans ce format un
petit peu un petit peu oui on va
s'arrêter là pour aujourd'hui je pense
que petit à petit je sais pas si on va
le faire dès le prochain épisode mais ça
peut être cool de lire vos histoires oui
évidemment que ce soit anonyme
évidemment vous soyez à l'aise avec
n'importe quoi que je puisse dire dessus
parce que moi je vais pas me priver
c'est le but du format sinon c'est pas
marrant donc je vais vous juger juger
peut-être votre famille vos relations
tout ça que vous soyez totalement à
l'aise avec ça en fait en le disant je
me rends compte que je sois si moi je
suis honnête on peut essayer je pense
pour la prochaine fois sur les divans
histoire d'en prendre une qui est la
vôtre sur laquelle je me sentirais à
l'aise que moi jamais aussi un peu
charrié voyez c'est ça qui est marrant
un peu en tout cas on va continuer ce
format une fois par mois et avant de
vous laisser
il faut que vous parle du sponsor de
cette vidéo kambly à vous l'avez vu donc
je traduis en temps réel beaucoup de
textes en anglais
parfois je vais les chercher quelques
mots etc et c'est l'anglais qui est très
conversationnel c'est l'anglais qui est
quasiment orale en fait si vous voulez
vous améliorez en anglais oral kambly ça
défonce parce que ça vous met en
directement en discussion avec des
natifs à l'oral c'est forcément des
natifs vous pouvez choisir l'accent donc
c'est quelqu'un d'australiens d'anglais
d'américains et c pourrait choisir
certains sujets des sujets qui vous
touche et vous pouvez aussi décidé de
préparer non seulement des euros ou un
entretien ce genre de choses mais en
plus par exemple des examens type toefl
tohic ce genre de truc humains coddh le
code cyrus north
il offre aux 40 % de réduction sur leur
abonnement d'un an et dix minutes de
visio gratos et je sais pas vous mais
moi avec avec le co villa avec vue qu'à
moins de voyages
il ya besoin d'interaction aussi avec
l'étranger j'ai l'impression est donc on
perd quand même un petit peu en pratique
combi c'est donc cool pour les gens qui
veulent améliorer leur anglais mais même
ceux qui veulent le maintenir
ça peut être pas mal donc je voulais
vous dire pour la prochaine vidéo si
vous voulez que
votre témoignage fasse partie de la
sélection
vous pouvez le mettre dans les
commentaires de cette vidéo là encore
une fois j'en prendrai qu'un seul et il
faut vraiment que vous soyez totalement
à l'aise avec pas d'ego je vous clash et
je vais vous éclater peut-être ok c'est
possible et faut que ce soit anonyme à
100% ça que modifiée même un petit peu
légèrement l'association qu'on puisse
pas comprendre que c'est vous enfin bref
voilà donc faut que vous soyez sereins
par rapport à ça love peace ciao
[Musique]